if it is graduation weekend for UNLV
students exciting times big ceremonies
today and tomorrow so you know you got
to turn the tassel and then you throw
the hat or cap or both right and then
you got to get a job
you're entering the workforce Laura
negrady joining us live from The
Newsroom to talk about the job market
outlook for all those graduating seniors
yes and it's a positive one at that the
UNLV Career Services executive director
says almost every sector students go
into has opportunities
UNLV career services staff say it can
take six months to get hired so here are
some quick tips Target your resume
toward the job you want research the
companies and reconnect within the week
of your interview you know a thank you
note can go so long and once a rebel
always a rebel no matter where they are
in their careers the staff will help
alums
we have career coaching of all kinds of
services resources
presentations we do Career Fairs events
our alumni continue to be a part of that
handshake platform has several job and
internship opportunities employers can
contact UNLV or connect with them via
handshake to post their own openings and
with graduation this weekend it's
interesting to note that unlv's top
undergrad programs include psychology
criminal justice and Hospitality
management top graduate programs law
social work and education all of which
are seeing opportunities live in The
Newsroom Laura Negrete 8 News Now